hey guys it is the 28th of January my
name is Jess makito and you're watching
games but news the titanfall alpha may
be all wrapped up but we finally have
some news on the beta so you won't have
to rely on those linked gameplay videos
for your mech shooter fix by much longer
that is as long as you have an xbox one
or PC since the xbox 360 is not on the
list of platforms which will get the
upcoming beta respawn CEO wisdom paula
has said on Twitter that will be
receiving more details in the next few
days prior to this revealed promotional
material was found which hinted that it
will probably take place on februari 14
to 19 it also suggested that the only
way to get in on the beta will be to
pre-order the game through gamestop in
the US and mike romania in france oh
that part is still all just rumors at
this point are you eager for the
titanfall beta or is there another
upcoming game that you're dying to get
your hands on let me know if that game
you're holding out for is Elder Scrolls
online then you'll probably be happy to
hear that ps4 users won't need to
purchase a PS Plus subscription on top
of the one they're already going to be
paying for the MMO the news came as
something of a cushioned blow for so
many fans with their eye on the game
since the MMOs own subscription fee is
already set at 1499 a month PlayStation
Plus only costs 50 bucks a year bud
ZeniMax online studios wanted to ensure
that players choosing to get in on the
title on ps4 weren't going to have to
walk out more than those on PC or Mac
but those two has also said it is
pushing Microsoft to remove the need for
Xbox one earners to have xbox live gold
accounts for the game let me know in the
comments down below if the pricing makes
you feel better about the game or if you
just don't want to pay fifteen dollars a
month under any circumstances in
excellent yet totally hypothetical and
completely unconcerned PlayStation used
to
it seems to the previous school may be
getting a ps1 and ps2 emulator a report
from digital foundry has suggested that
backwards compatibility to ps1 and ps2
titles is coming to the ps4 and that
these games will be emulated locally on
your console not on Sony's new streaming
technology PlayStation now which will
only support ps3 titles at this point in
time Sony's internal emulator is already
being used with the ps3 and Vita but the
ps4 is supposedly set to gain the
ability to run all the titles with the
possibility of HD visual enhancements
emulating titles locally as opposed to
streaming may result in a significant
graphical advantage and non-existent
input lag which ps1 or ps2 game would be
your go-to title if the new turns out to
be true you can leave me your pics
either in the comments down below or on
my Twitter where I'm at justice tunnel
that's it for me and most early next
sent today but i'll be back same times
markovic sneeze you're after then this
is definitely the place to be I'll see
you see